ce pays est un pays de rêves
peut être un endroit dur
un endroit cruel
mais c'est là que je travaille
je rêve d'une vie meilleure pour mon fils
alors que pensez-vous du camion de glasgow
c'est bien je l'ai déjà vu avant
qu'il ne soit plus frappé par l'explosion  c'est à nous
depuis que nous avons obtenu une licence pour dire que trop
fort d'accord ce camion est ma seule chance
de faire en sorte que cela devienne quelque chose de grand
afin que nous puissions sortir d'ici et te mettre
dans une meilleure école
bien fils ouais je dois rebondir d'accord
louie
dois  parler de ton
avenir je vais faire quelque chose de
cette affaire bon pour toi
bon pour nous
ce qui s'est passé ils l'ont volé ils ont braqué
le camion je dois le trouver d'accord je
viens avec toi s'il te plait c'est mon
problème
toi